absolutely i don't like the games i
don't like people yeah i do i feel like
there's a lot of like um childish stuff
that goes with toxicity
which i don't like okay i think it
depends on so i don't think you like the
toxicity i think you like the person or
maybe you do like the toxicity because
you like that person like it's a part of
them mm-hmm but i just feel like you're
more attractive person so you take that
mm-hmm you know how that's happened or
for worse yeah you kind of take that
from them
i get what you're saying but for better
for words
as soon as you show me worse i'm out
i feel like you know we can do better
for ourselves
it depends on how much you want for
yourself like if you say do you know
what i want better i have this standard
up here like for me right now i'm like
i'm there's a standard i want
there's like a level of
commitment
and
um
generosity and attitude and behavior i
want from a person
so it's like i hold that so sacred i
feel like it depends on how you hold
yourself
so you can say no
depending on like even if you really
love that person it's like you want
yourself more i think it's also the fact
that you expect the best out of your
partner like you see them in such a
highlight that you don't expect them to
treat you poorly until it happens and
you're like well they've never done this
before so they won't do it again yeah so
again and you're like
what's going on here and you keep
letting them do it and you're like damn
okay
but i love them so much because we stuck
through all of this garbage but we don't
need to
so that's why love is blind
don't get me started about that show
wait so so question when how long were
you in the relationship before you
realized it was toxic because for me it
didn't start out that way did it start
out that way for you guys
[Music]
an act i feel like or maybe they have
this
ideology they want to be
and i think that's what it was in my
scenario they had this ideology of who
they want to be and they acted like that
i believed it
more for me
and
i believed it and then obviously you get
when you get deep into a relationship
you even when you're around that person
a lot you get to see a lot of their
traits good or bad
um you get to see a lot of their
behavior their attitudes how they react
to situations how they handle situation
when you have an argument which is okay
in a relationship
arguments are toxic i think it's just
how you handle that argument
um how they handle situations and then
you're like oh that's not you that's not
how you portrayed yourself to be and
they like they put up this image so
you're like oh
so why when the toxic stuff happens why
don't we leave right away because we're
so we're so like
no
i leave like
you know as soon as you show me
something different i'm out like i ain't
gonna give you the second chance to do
something it comes from experience yeah
because as a teenager i was dumb enough
to stick around i'm just like that's my
man i'm gonna stick this out
you really don't need to and after i
realized my worth after i realized like
that's it [ __ ] i'm amazing period
surely
it is never the hot girl i was like
worried about
no i think it's like also attachment
issues like you're kind of attached to
what you have like for me in my
experience i can speak on it um for
example like for the first maybe a month
it was great and it was locked this is
locked down locked down so it's like
when kobe had started see that's not the
time
during the pandemic
you're lying because you can't you can't
go out you can't go wrong
with everybody all right i don't know
which one you're buying
unless you're talking about brothers
i didn't
as well like i was in my relationship
like lockdown like prior to right before
lockdown but then lockdown happened so
i'm stuck in that so you're in a bubble
as well
so it was like oh my god so i feel like
you get this facade mm-hmm and then
you're kind of
for example i know you have attachment
and she's
hiking on the loki
that was like a big thing like so it's
like i'm like i'll be stick like ride
you through that and then it's like you
don't really see a lot of things when
you're kind of in this bubble you're
like you put them on this pedestal like
you're so attracted to them like the
problem is
no actually actually question is is the
toxic relationship that you were in the
best sex you've ever had yeah
no no no no no
but yeah
like do you ever hear like what you
shouldn't have is what is the best thing
like that you'll ever enjoy but what you
should do for yourself that's actually
what's actually best for you isn't
always easiest and that's why it's more
i'm sorry i had to do mental gymnastics
to get through that i'm sorry like
wait wait wait actually
it's like what's best for you is always
the hardest thing to do for you yourself
because it's like
you really need to go through the
hardest stuff you need all that
discipline self like self discipline the
problem is we get comfortable
yeah can't be out of your comfort zone
all of that in order to really do what's
best for that it's never ever going to
be easy i think we always think it is
like yeah we can have easy sex and great
sex with a guy that's toxic but
in five years or in actually let me give
you six months or two more weeks
two weeks no actually
it's gonna it's gonna affect your life
it affects your mentality it affects how
your future relationships whether that's
a relationship with your future husband
um or actually your partner like girl
boy or your friendships it affects how
you act in that because that's where
trust issues stems from a lot of issues
do stem from that it could be from your
family other issues
so yeah so question for the people who
come from good relationships good homing
good everything and they can get in and
talk to you later and they can mess them
up for the toxic relationship you were
in how long were you in it
okay two months three full months
it depends on which one i'm talking
about
but we're going to talk about the worst
one yeah it took like two years two
years but it was codependency
you know two years on and off though
two years
three months laughing three months so
oh so you guys you get the basketball
girls leave
i told you as soon as you switch up i'm
not giving you another chance to switch
up on me i'm like bye
where he messed up and then i think he
tried to check me about that because he
felt so powerful around me like looking
at his phone or something and i was like
i don't think you're actually being a
joke
[Music]
i'm actually too good for this i think
for me to be fair like for that two-year
relationship that was when i was 18.
yeah i was like 18 19. so you know like
this was my first time in college being
with somebody like super close all the
time like because you know my parents
were on my ass like they're not gonna
let no boy come into the house oh yeah
so
it was like that codependency kicked in
very fast because i was around them all
the time and i just let [ __ ] slide and
he let [ __ ] slide on my end too
feel bad for him on that but yeah he
definitely did me worse than i did him
i'm not gonna lie to you
but i grew from that relationship and i
figured out how to get my [ __ ] together
and realize like i definitely deserve
way better than this so then did you
never have a toxic relationship again
since then no actually okay so for the
most part they were healthy
from that i feel like that's where we
actually need to play off like we need
to accept our part in this stuff right
we can talk about toxic men who we like
yeah you were toxic too okay
okay
man
i definitely gone through my man's phone
like
tonight wait wait out of everyone here
how many have gone through a guy's phone
before
never
i haven't since then not my phone so
basically with my
cool a few more before mom's into it
coming
like there was a time i was like
he was acting so jealous and i was like
why are you acting so jealous like there
must be something you want to hide
so for the first time in my whole life
in my whole relationship life
i went through his laptop
oh okay what'd you find yeah it happened
to me so you know how much
so i'm confident i'm like oh this is
your ex thing this is your ex
what's going on here i'm not remembering
facetime calls and you're in a
relationship with me well i'm seeing
text messages i'm like no wait this is
crazy so i also feel like we do play our
plot like essentially like it takes two
mm-hmm i always believe that like i
would never blame the guy for everything
that's happening now they ship the yeah
messy calls me mentally right because i
feel like i also enabled it tonight well
and we and we make a choice to stay so
you can't you can't say
yeah to make it work if you're after
until the point where you got paranoid
and i was like no if this when you're in
love you really forget what logic is yes
like your emotions really choose to
believe the better
therapists actually
literally will not take certain like
clients that are in love because your
brain chemistry is so different when
you're in that state of like love and
infatuation
so like and therapists also say like
cheating like goes two ways like you can
enable that behavior that brings someone
to that level where they cheat on you
you know they think it's okay like if we
allow them to think it's okay it's like
when you're a mom like if you allow your
child to fix certain behaviors okay
they're going to carry on doing it if
you don't check your child with their
ass like they're going to be thinking
it's okay like you should have ripped
your sons off and maybe he would have
been better
so so next next question do you guys
have you guys ever stayed after cheating
yes i've never had that happen to me
remember you guys got it
being cheated on
yeah yeah yeah being being cheated on no
physically physically okay
yeah i definitely did but in the 18 year
old relationship yeah okay but to be
fair we were going through a difficult
time where we decided that we weren't
going to be together but we were still
stuck on each other all the time like we
weren't on the same page about where our
relationship was supposed to go and
whether we were fully together
and that created a lot of issues because
there was always miscommunications and
like you shouldn't be talking to that
[ __ ] but then you know he can though
like i can't stop him yeah so you guys
weren't actually together
exactly
what was you guys doing like sorry um
were you guys in the official
relationship was that established we
were at first and [ __ ] got tough like i
would go into detail but it's like it's
really really personal you know like
it's really tough and i don't want to
put him in a bad spot if he saw this
right now he'd be like yo what's up
because we're actually friends now like
we grew so much and actually came
together and were like yo i still got
love for you yeah like you're still my
homie like you were my best friend at
the end of the day and you were the
person that was there for me and through
every single bad thing that happened
we just weren't compatible
relationship-wise because we
how to communicate we didn't understand
what a relationship really meant it
wasn't just loving someone hard and like
sometimes
it was actually communicating with each
other understanding what our problems
were with each other and yeah working
through that and i'm telling each other
as a person exactly it's a whole
different ballgame relationship it is
do you okay next question okay
oh god have you got some [ __ ] [ __ ]
have you ever
slept with the toxic x after you guys
broke up yeah yep
i wouldn't even count make sure you're
grabbing
part of toxicity is like super
highlights highs really low yes you hang
on to those high highs right and then
it's like you're chasing that high right
it's like an addiction like yeah you're
chasing those good times
jess is like i got nothing to contribute
type situation and it's like i think you
hold this expectation to how it's going
to be
well that's what they do it doesn't end
you end up being so attached to that
person like you want that and that's
like do you know what i feel like
mentally to the point you can you get to
an extent you can be like that's all you
would expect from them because you know
what they really like like you know the
toxicity
in that situation you came out of that
you dealt with that you moved past that
you healed from that but then it's like
sexually do you know what yeah you can
do that for me
it's like but then i would and it's like
she's like jess is like these [ __ ]
are crazy
you can satisfy me on that
certain perspective aspect you can like
you know what in that area
you're you're great you're actually
you're effing
excuse me
you're top tier but then it's like
really intriguing do i really want that
energy inside you so that's why you go
there like you're like you know what you
are great like it's it's longer to go to
a different guy who doesn't know what
you like yeah like know how you are yeah
he doesn't he hasn't studied your body
yeah you haven't set your who wants that
up there body count that's another thing
there's a lot of aspects so you do go
there and you're like oh sex but it's
really not like it's really toxic sex
are you ending your toxic energy going
inside me now i'm toxic